[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
super excited to be talking about
disinformation
media and trust we have Rene to wrested
joining us on the show thank you for
having me thank you so much for coming
on I'm very excited for this they do you
crushed it on Rogan and Sam Harris you
did you did so well teaching about your
work
Renee deressa for those that don't know
is a mozilla fellow and media
misinformation and trust she
investigates the spread of malign
narratives across social networks and
assists policymakers in understanding
and responding to the problem
she has advised Congress the State
Department and other academic civic and
business organizations and has studied
disinformation and computational
propaganda in the context of
pseudoscience conspiracies terrorism and
state-sponsored
information warfare and you can find the
links in the bio below to renee to rest
calm as well as her twitter no upside
and also highly recommend downloading
the white paper and slide deck from
disinformation report.com and looking at
those we'll have a bunch of the images
throughout the show that we'll be
discussing and also just a crazy thing
the generative adversarial network these
idea of deep fakes
this site creates fake images of people
you can find it this person does not
exist calm will mention that towards the
end of the show as well and even before
we start with renee i want to read about
some of the findings that they wrote
about in the white paper in the slide
deck it's just a couple quick paragraphs
and they'll give you an idea of what
we're gonna talk about upon request by
the United States Senate Select
Committee on Intelligence SSCI new
knowledge reviewed an expansive data set
of social media posts and metadata
provided to SSCI by Facebook Twitter and
alphabet plus a set of related data from
additional platforms the data provided
to SSC I clearly illustrates that for
approximately five years Russia has
waged a propaganda war against American
citizens manipulating social media
narratives to influence American culture
and politics the internet research
agency IRA began its operations in
mid-2013 in Saint Petersburg Russia run
like a sophisticated marketing agency in
a centralized office environment the IRA
employed and trained over a thousand
people
engage in round-the-clock influencer
operations first targeting Ukrainian and
Russian citizens and then well before
the 2016 US election Americans the scale
of their operation was unprecedented
they reached a hundred and twenty-six
million people on Facebook at least 20
million users on Instagram 1.4 million
users on Twitter and uploaded over 1,000
videos to YouTube as the DOJ indictments
have recently revealed this manipulation
of American political discourse had a
budget that exceeded 25 million US
dollars you find all this information
again on disinformation report com on
the white paper and slide deck Renee I
can't believe that you guys got all this
data and ended up scraping through it
and coming up with these insights it's
just it's insane what's going on in our
world with exponential technology so the
first question I want to ask you is what
are your thoughts on the direction of
our world
um I you know as pertains to this
cautiously optimistic I think we've made
a lot of headway in building connections
between researchers and tech platforms
between both of those two entities in
government civil society we've got a lot
more in the way of collaborative
understanding of the problem
how did we're we're working on solutions
for how to best detect the problem we're
working on policies for how to mitigate
and try to preempt the problem so we're
in a better place than we were in I
would say 2014 2015 when we were still
trying to decide if this was a problem
and what we should do about it that said
you know it's it's an arms race as we
get better at detecting they get better
at evading and so it's sort of
constantly a kind of cat-and-mouse
adversaries evolving as the platforms
change the rules as the rules change how
do we improve our detection to find what
they do next and so that's it's kind of
where we are it's definitely interesting
job ad Awards they used arms race I
won't really want to highlight those and
amplify them because we got to figure
out hopefully how did you politically
work together and not necessarily have
an arms race but rather a collaborative
process of figuring out how to be
together on this rock and I'm sure we'll
you know we'll hit on that later in the
show
Renet I want to learn about your
background I think it's really important
to highlight this so you grew up in
yonkers and you went to Stony Brook yeah
okay and then you spend some time in
Wall Street and then you moved out to
the Bay Area and started doing this for
like bus eight-years
teach us about how you got like hooked
into computer science and yeah yeah well
computer science my dad's an engineer so
I learned to code when I was 9 or so
they this is embarrassing but they
actually like he kind of bribed me
almost he was like they have this like
collection of VHS tapes member back in
the day or VHS tapes they're like build
a database of the VHS tapes in the house
and like what drawer they're in because
me did you remember this leg back in the
olden days you actually go like hunting
for your video tape to watch in your VHS
projector so they said my dad was like
right write a program so that we have a
like as like a library so we can find
videotapes in the house of course it's
the thing for a kid to do and and my
prize was like I would get to go to
Disney World if I did it and so I took
me like eight months but I mean now I've
got two kids of my own and I think like
man that was real conviction and how do
i how do I do that with my own you know
my own children how do I teach my
five-year-old who's already obsessed
with YouTube and and you know wants to
make videotapes of himself doing things
and I cringe a little bit inside it you
know how do you navigate these waters as
a parent but also I'm excited that there
is so much interesting you know
interesting technology that he has
access to and I feel like a lot of what
I do is think about how do you how do I
use the skills that I have to create the
kind of world that I want him to live in
and then simultaneously how do i impart
some of that love of technology and
simultaneously a respect for technology
while working to you know that to
transform some of the negative
externalities that we've become aware of
in the last couple years yeah navigating
the waters of raising kids into the
exponential technology era good luck and
okay how about with the computer science
and moving into how did I get into this
specifically
moving in Wall Street so what were the
profound realizations there and what
made you move out here Wall Street I did
it's it's called high-frequency trading
now I guess but we called it automated
market making it was I was on Wall
Street from 2004 to 2011 at a firm
called Jane Street I started there as a
clerk actually I started there just as
somebody with a computer science
bachelor's degree who wrote you know
scrapers and things actually at the time
and it really weren't much in the way of
API is thinking about how do we run
calculations overnight implied
volatility for options models
I learned I'd never taken a finance
class but I really liked math and so it
was a great place to be where I got to
learn from people and then put my skills
to kind of extremely you know tangible
use just and then I I switched over to
the other side of the aisle we called it
kind of and instead of just being a
programmer and a clerk I became a trader
so then I started working on developing
mathematical models for pricing
derivatives and it was a fascinating
time to be on Wall Street independent of
the 2008 financial crisis and the
European debt crisis just in terms of
seeing how technology transformed the
markets kind of leading into that so
there's macroeconomic situations that
that unfolded as I was actually a trader
but more than that there was also the
incorporation of technology into every
facet of trading and so it was
fascinating time to be on Wall Street
just to live through that so I was a
trader during the 2008 financial crisis
and through the European debt crisis and
then I left in 2011 I just I felt like I
had been through this extraordinary
period and things were kind of settling
down into something more routine again
and I just felt like if I was ever gonna
go jump and do something else
like that was the time I was turning 30
so there was this weird number that that
was kind of associated with it too and
I'd never lived in California but I met
Bryce Roberts who was at O'Reilly alpha
tech ventures one of the partners there
and I just got really interested in the
idea of what it what what were markets
in new and emerging companies like I'd
spent all this time working in public
markets with an abundance of data doing
extremely quantitative work I had no
network I knew almost nobody because
Wall Street is very insular you kind of
know the people on your trading desk
maybe you don't talk about what you do
and so I moved out to the valley because
I wanted a network I wanted to learn
about venture capital I wanted to be
around ideas I was useless as an
engineer by this point so that's like I
can't go be an engineering tech company
like Jane Street everything was like oh
camel and Visual Basic which is
completely useless I tried like learning
Rails and brushing up on skills again
for a hot second and then decided that
was probably not the best use of energy
yeah came out here I had a great
opportunity meet Tim O'Reilly as the oh
is the O'Reilly behind O'Reilly Auto
tech ventures and he's been such an
inspirational figure in the valley in
terms of the idea of create more value
than you capture and how do we invest in
technology not but not just that it's
going to be the the the biggest or the
best but how do you think about a more
ethical capitalism how do you think
about ethical companies how do you
invest in companies that are solving
real problems and that was the ethos at
OU a TV and so I was kind of fortunate
to come out to the valley and for
someone liked him to to support me and
in the way that he did and then I got
into this stuff actually is like a side
project at night I just I really missed
I missed quantitative work that was the
thing about seed stage venture capital
it's very much
you know it's very much about the
founder and the idea there's not a lot
of data there's not a lot of numbers and
I found myself kind of missing that and
so I started teaching myself data
visualization at night and trying to
connect with people who were looking at
data sets to solve interesting problems
and I wound up getting really involved
in the Andy Andy the anti anti vaccine
movement I guess the Pro you know Pro
vaccine advocacy but not so much the
advocacy side more of the how do we
understand and map how anti Beck's
activity is spreading on social networks
that was a question that was really
interesting to me as a new parent I'd
you know how to have my first baby by
that point and I just started
downloading datasets and connecting with
data scientists and starting to
investigate that question and then
through that process began to realize
that there was some really interesting
dynamics about how the social ecosystem
fit together that were that appeared to
be somewhat problematic in terms of the
way that they allowed extremely small
groups of people to have extraordinary
amplification and ways in which that
could be a force for good a force for
you know giving a voice to people who
previously didn't have one but also if
you layered in a little bit more in the
way of manipulation a little bit in the
way of automation potentially disastrous
and so that was what got me interested
in how narrative spread online yeah whoa
okay so then oh yeah all the way to the
you know in the Wall Street days not
being able to build out the network that
you wanted doing high frequency trading
kind of like the complexities of that
also just applying all the automation
technologies that were going on during
that time going through the 2008-2009
crisis and also then coming out of it
and finding O'Reilly out here out west
and and being able to build a network
being able to build C companies that had
a strong ethos and wanting to help them
that kind of stuff also gets us going we
love talking about that as well but then
at the very end you're like you got
interested because you had a kid in the
sea yeah you yeah you talked about this
before I really like this point just
that because you had a kid and that you
were seeing a lot of the
anti-vaccination you wanted to visualize
how it was that social media dynamics
were causing such vast amplification of
such small amounts of people and I think
that's quite an interesting way to get
to kind of get yourself involved in in
the craziness of data visualization and
social dynamics okay and then there's
several other things that have gotten
you to you know to where you are today
at Mozilla but also passing some time
with with new knowledge being able to
understand this data set that you got so
so let's yeah there's so many assets in
here that we should go through yeah so
the United States Senate Select
Committee on Intelligence that SSCI
got data metadata from Facebook Twitter
and alphabet yes and then that data was
analyzed by two groups one of them was
new knowledge yes and the other was a
grafica and Oxford internet Institute
out of Oxford University blocks readers
yes so that was a sort of collaborative
second team grafica is a tech company
that looks at network analysis is there
kind of core business and they look at
how our conversation is being shaped
online who are the influential nodes in
the network what our themes had as
information spread and they focus very
much on Twitter they do beautiful
visualizations so we put our stuff up on
the landing page disinformation report
but grafica also has a great collection
of their own analysis they the Senate
ran it with multiple teams because they
didn't want either a queue you know you
want to see given the same data set do
researchers reach the same conclusions
particularly about something as
sensitive as election interference in
2016 which as will I'm sure discuss is
only a part of what happened
but it's a political football and how do
you how do you ensure that if only one
team does the research is very easy to
you know discredit or to say that the
researcher is biased but by doing this
kind of blind process we didn't know
graphic I was doing it they didn't know
we were doing it oh cool
yeah so we didn't communicate with them
until the very end and the findings were
somewhat suck as I haven't seen ya the
findings are you know extremely similar
they focused a little bit more on the
Twitter data we focused more on the
Facebook and Instagram data partly
because that was that was actually you
know the Senate was recognized that
certain tech companies like new
knowledge and grafica have that
complimentary in this case capabilities
and so we spent a little bit more time
on the Instagram and they spent a little
more time on Twitter okay but the
findings were largely the same and then
and then I want to know how exactly the
data came in because yeah cuz I think we
won't spend too much time the technical
weeds but like how did all the data come
in and how did you guys even begin
trying to understand how to scrape it
for your information yeah so the Senate
began holding hearings into Russian
interference on social media back in
October and November 2017 and as part of
that I had connected with people on the
committee via Tristan Harris and Roger
McNamee who were going down to DC
somewhat regularly encouraging the
Senate to hold these hearings and I
became part of that process because I
felt that this was becoming so
politicized and there were just huge
person you know huge segments of the
population that just didn't believe it
happened even and so we said okay if the
Senate holds hearings the tech platforms
will come and they themselves will
acknowledge that it happened and so
maybe we can bypass this idea that it's
all a democratic you know figment
fantasy kind of thing and it's a this is
the first conversation I've had about
this post Miller report coming out and
so let me just caveat just right off the
bat with collusion and interference are
two separate things I was never asked to
investigate collusion that was entirely
side of the scope of what I was asked to
look at was I what I was asked to look
at was given the data set that was
attributed by the platform so at no
point did I say these accounts are
Russian the platforms established that
themselves they gave the data to the
Senate the Senate tasked research teams
grafica and Oxford with analyzing the
data so that's how did Facebook and
Twitter and alphabet know that these
accounts were from IRA yeah so that is a
very interesting question and that was
never divulged to us so as you'll if you
read the my caveat I in the methodology
section it's to the best of my knowledge
assuming the attribution is correct here
is your analysis I think that so when we
think about a disinformation campaign
one of the steps in that process is
amassing operationalize Abal assets so
fake accounts fake pages email addresses
the creation of things that are going to
be deployed through the course of the
operation
sometimes the operation is discreet it's
here you usually see that with like
trolls more like a here's a campaign to
change people's perception about one
moment in time this was a multi-year
process so when you have a long game
they build up these assets and
oftentimes if they're sloppy what you'll
see is they'll recycle an email address
they'll be an IP block that is used
they'll be they were reusing the Yandex
tags and some of the website code they
had let's see AdWords accounts that were
shared across a couple of the pages so
the the platforms have access to
metadata about account creation and
things like that
no outside researcher can see that stuff
so when we're looking at campaigns we're
looking at it from dissemination
patterns repetitive use of content it's
a different process so that was the they
did the attribution though yeah okay so
this is so social platforms did the
attribution and they have the data that
showed them that they thought that this
came from Ira yes and then that then you
guys do the analysis data set so now
what what do you get then and how like
you said there's this there's
dissemination pattern
and content and what what what does the
dataset look like that you get and then
how do you start scraping it for
information um about four hundred gigs
and folders so it was PDFs as a disaster
it took us about a month and a half to
do what's called clean the data which is
just to put it into some sort of format
that is standardized well across a
database so to create a database
taxonomy to create a way that we can
think about interrelated assets so a
post has metadata about the post it has
the content of the post it has the image
content it has the text content it has
the account name so you're thinking
about this in terms of how do you design
a schema to make this a to standardize
content across datasets provided from
three platforms because ultimately you
want to understand what's happening in
each silo but more importantly you want
to understand what this looks like
across the entire ecosystem so to about
a month and a half just to extract you
know because you want URLs to be if you
want to know what URLs they tweeted the
most do you have to have your URLs in a
you know in a table where you can do
that kind of aggregation and things and
so the first step in doing this is more
of a forensic analysis than a detection
campaign as I said the attribution was
already done I was just asked to analyze
it as opposed to go find more Russian
content based on this which was
something that we did as part of the
investigation but we were tasked with
report on what this content so month and
a half on cleaning it and then after
that the exploratory period how do you
what do you ask what do we want to know
I mean we during the cleaning process we
to data scientists on the cleaning by
the way the data set was nd8 so the
company did not do the analysis six of
us within the company and two of us
outside the company did the analysis so
it was siloed in such a way
it wasn't a new knowledge project and
quite the same way it was like a team of
people so we had to really work on how
do you recognizing that people have
actual jobs and things that they have to
do how do we allocate like resources to
put people on this project so while two
data scientists were working on the
database schema three others of us were
in a Word document thinking about what
we're going to ask and what you know so
that was a conversation of what does the
Senate want to know what do we know from
the media what are the gaps in our
knowledge some of it was just running
queries looking at keywords phrases
things that come up
some of it is summary statistics which
is what appears the most what image is
the most popular had images hopped from
platform to platform what did they do
over time so not just not just quantity
but longitudinal over again this is
several years right how does the
conversation in 2012 look versus the
conversation in 2018 why are there
spikes and account creation around these
dates what's happening in the real world
how can we trace back memes that go
viral with moments in the real world can
we look at the data and say this is what
they created themselves versus this is
what they appropriated from real
American news sources it's just so much
to ask
yeah um say maybe eight months or so of
work yeah to NIMH even with eight months
of work and I think I wrote like 260
pages or something there was still a
feeling of did we answer everything you
know did we so the molar report comes
out the first thing I do is go back to
my pull up the data set again and
compare molars footnotes with what I
know to be true and you know every new
story that comes out you treat it as
like a bread crumb that can lead you to
find out something interesting about the
operation yeah okay a couple things
first is you also said that on the
Instagram and Facebook you guys don't
get any data Priya
right on those two platforms yeah I just
also want to just just for on a
technical side of things database schema
and spending well just spending six
weeks on trying to take four hundred
gigs of data and put it into some sort
of a cohesive database that you can then
query that's very tough and then you
have to query for things like you said
like the date the image the URLs all
this type of stuff and like this is this
is a lot of tough technical nuance got
to be able to handle and we have a bunch
of these that we can go over as we talk
so because there's so many also
technical applications that you could
potentially leverage like I'm curious
how much because you had to do some
image recognition to be able to see if
yeah to see if if one was used on a
Facebook and one was used on Instagram
yeah we did image clustering for
similarity varying degrees of similarity
exact match versus in the slide deck I
put out we did things like you know
there's a cluster of images in the shape
of Texas right because they had a Texas
secessionist page that doesn't really
give us any remarkable insight but you
do just run sort of a series of image
analysis to look at did they use the
same image across their pages did they
repeat the same image within a page how
did they treat high-performing content
can we flag in images this is
high-performing content did it Traverse
more widely did they leverage it and
reuse it again with with with Twitter we
had a real interesting challenge which
was the URL data was not given to us
unrolled so it came in TECO links yeah
so you couldn't immediately put that
into a database and have any meaningful
insights into what the URLs were grafica
did the labor-intensive work of actually
unrolling all of that stuff since we
were focused more on Instagram and
and Facebook we didn't but one of the
things that we could see was for a lot
of the Tico links the image that would
come in was actually the logo of the
news domain so using that as almost like
a breadcrumb we could see over time
there use of things like cnn.com and
newyorktimes.com and then gradually as
the operation went on you started to see
more of these news logos from local news
so you would see them grabbing you know
media from I think Colorado in Denver
and Baltimore and so you would see these
local news logos beginning to kind of
populate in the data set so that was
just sort of an interesting thing that
was that actually emerged via image you
know just our look at images over time
as opposed to actually having that
proven out with the URL data and I think
that recently somebody's gone through
and looked at the unrolled URLs and kind
of corroborated that that was happening
that they moved more into local at the
time so that was nice to see also they
like when you said that there is also
this process of going into like a word
doc and actually being able to say what
does the Senate what would they want us
to think figuring out so you're
constantly working with your team on
asking all of the hard questions and
figuring out what exactly you want to
take from the data to actually be able
to say like we addressed the vast
majority of the hard questions so what
we saw before was a timeline and you
indicated that yeah you have create
these things like spike periods why are
there spike periods these are the
top-performing individual content on
Facebook and so these are the things
like this is almost a million
engagements on the acid on the right I
was banned from television for being too
violent like and sure if you grew up
watching me on television have a gun and
having shot or killed anyone
and then if like and sure if you think
our veterans must give benefits before
refugees that had seven hundred
twenty-five thousand total engagements
on Facebook so these are huge numbers
these are massive
and we believe then that these assets
were created by the internet research
agency and then disseminated through
Facebook pages that the more kind of
polarizing the content could get the
more that it would harm the country's
discourse yes but also a lot of what
they were doing was like like this thing
here I was banned from TV for being too
violent like and share if you haven't
shot or killed somebody that was posted
on a page that was about southern pride
and there's a you know confederate flag
behind it a lot of it was like hat you
know reinforcing tribalism like that's
very much like her right on like yeah i
feel that two people act like guns are
such a big deal but really I've had a
gun and I haven't killed anybody so it's
more of like a yes and kind of like I
feel that too and there was a I don't
know on Instagram there is a I think the
top-performing content was a picture of
a shoe company yeah I think yeah we have
that one will come up as well okay yeah
yeah alright so I'll say I'll say that
but but that at that again was sort of a
yes I thought that was related to how
hard it you know what it means for a
black woman to hear the word nude and
nude refers to like kind of a beige
color that's like me more and so not so
much you know when a black woman here is
nude that is a kind of like is a
reinforcement that you're maybe not what
this was designed for and so that got a
lot of likes because that again is sort
of like very much like yes I you know I
feel that pain kind of like in
solidarity so a lot of it is like how
you build these tribes where you're
reinforcing and identity particularly an
identity that feels itself perhaps
alienated from or has a sense of
grievance or a detachment from like
mainstream American society and
oftentimes these grievances are rooted
in very real cultural moments but what
what an operation like this does is it
seeks to reinforce that feeling of
division to widen existing rifts as
opposed to you know it's not Russia
didn't create racism American Society
Russia didn't create the tension between
kind of the Confederate pride versus
racism kind of framing there and the
exacerbation exactly yeah and so then
that can lead to serious if if just
thought about it like a mimetic warfare
perspective just in the sense that if
you do disseminate you know that tens of
thousands of pieces of content get
millions and millions of engagements hit
hundreds of millions of people what ends
up happening is you end up having these
deep impacts on people's cognition where
the way that they think about having a
conversation with someone that disagrees
with them is shattered that you can't
have that conversation that nuance gets
shattered and that can hurt a country in
the long run and people in the long run
and then this was also interesting
because there was a you know these
thousands of people that are hired by
the internet research agency also have a
understanding of American culture enough
to say that lefty can enjoy drinking
milk because it promotes white supremacy
I'm pretty sure that that was repurposed
I don't think that was an original
creation I think it went back and looked
over it somewhere original that was that
is a ongoing colossal pain in the butt
as far as analysis because the whole
point of means that they go viral and so
they trace back to the original source
is extremely difficult particularly
because a lot of the time when you're
doing something like using a google
reverse image search or Tanai or the
other kind of Yandex commercially
available tools if it has that angry
eagle that was a brand mark that they
named a page an Instagram account angry
eagle once that brand mark is on there
if you have the same image with a
different brand mark it doesn't always
flag so sometimes it still does it
depends on what percentage similarity is
still there sometimes they would take
something and they would kind of change
it a little bit more dramatically we've
gone to grayscale you know did any sorts
of things but you you
figuring out where it came from is an
interesting challenge ultimately they do
repurpose real American content which
means that all they have to do is
amplify hyper-partisan sentiment and in
this particular operation from 2014 to
2018 they worked to make their own pages
and so it was important to them to frame
themselves as independent media so they
stuck brown marks on everything but I
don't think that that's where it's going
that's part of the problem right because
you don't need to you are much more
vulnerable to detection if you're trying
to amass this page and frame yourself as
an independent media outlet that people
might go scrutinize verses to just kind
of drop memes that come from real
legitimate sources that everybody knows
they're just amplify a hyper partisan
point of view as opposed to create your
own yeah understand a culture so there's
this this idea that if you can start
several years ago and build up the
dozens of pages that are slowly kind of
developing they're in their youthful
years and and then you can take and
scrape content from existing partisan
pages and then just reshare that content
on the pages that you've been developing
over several years and developing
follower ships also you can create your
own unique content and also be
distributing that with again these
different and we'll talk about
repurposing in a little bit yeah so
there's these different ways of handling
this all right let's hit the next one
Ronnie this was the top Facebook
performer for Donald Trump yeah
in force referencing Donald Trump and
this was for stop all invaders
was the page there was an immigration
focus page so the one of the things that
was interesting was like as we looked at
the Trump Hillary content had it you
know how did we quantify what was Trump
and Hillary content so some of that is
like who appears an image or whose name
appears in the image but for Hillary
they had 20 different nicknames Hillary
Hillary you know there's all the
and so we were like all right so what is
our corpus of names for the
identification looking through this 400
gigs like how do we extract stuff that
relates to to Trump and Hillary so I was
an interesting vanishing challenge but
with this is this is January 2017 so
this is after the election yep and again
the themes of like who is an American
preying on like this weird conspiracy
theory that somebody is going to
establish Sharia law on American soil
this is the thing that pops up in
right-wing fever swamps occasionally but
is not a thing that is really
mainstreamed but they do take more
obscure hyper-partisan fear-based
narratives and push that out and that
can get three hundred and twelve
thousand shares yeah hyper-partisan
fear-based narratives there's the the
next one is the top hillary clinton
performer and this one's like if you
agree on what louis session should be
allowed to vote and then they said
seventy seven thousand shares yep so
this was so there was no there were none
actually no pro-hillary memes on
facebook or instagram
none were pro know there was one and i
don't know if it's in here but secondly
in the deck there was an ad encouraging
muslims to rally in support of hillary
although so so verbally you might argue
that that is a post and supported
Hillary Clinton but you know what they
really were going for their it was like
let's have a let's have groups of
Muslims come out and rally to support
Hillary Clinton the middle of Washington
DC the goal is to create a spectacle
that they could then use at you know to
to create fear which is like look at
Muslims which is this group that they
were using that they were consistently
demonizing on the right wing targeted
pages so that would have been a great
collection of new media assets for them
to to draw on
so there were there were no probe
propene there were there were some
anti-trump posts to be clear yeah
so the they roughly grouped their pages
into right wing left wing and then the
black community got its own special 33
pages dedicated to the black community
on Facebook alone Wow and so they did
segment out race focused so while black
Americans mostly are Democrats and
left-leaning not all but most
they still treated that as a separate
silo versus generic left-wing content so
there was anti-trump content in the
generic left-wing content because of
course if you're running a left-wing
meme page it would be easily discovered
if you were all of a sudden putting out
you know pro Trump stuff on there so
what they were doing there was it was
anti Clinton and Pro Jill Stein and Pro
Bernie Sanders and so and after Bernie
Sanders was out of the election Pro Jill
Stein and Pro not voting and we'll have
some data visualizations as well as we
go through and this clustering that
you're talking about let's just go to
the next and there's this targeting
Americans so what was the deal this is
one of the pages called black devices or
one of the 33 pages okay
this video may bring you to tears make
it go viral we need this unity in our
communities and again it's about pride
so really that's what there is what
they're going for it was you know the
they did a lot of targeting by race in
the in the ads and so the way that you
do that is you target by interests and
so you would see things like interests
Malcolm X interests Martin Luther King
interests you know various facets of
black culture I think there's something
I think I definitely noted this there's
something about behavior like African
American behavior so the ad targeting on
Facebook if you've never run a Facebook
ad can't you maybe have run a Facebook
ad for your page or something right so
you know that you've got the ad tool you
can go demographically you can go
regionally you can go by interest you
can go by behavior
you can go by look-alike audiences and
custom audiences which are more
sophisticated and so we did see evidence
of we didn't see evidence of look-alike
that wasn't included there were a couple
of custom audiences but we didn't have
the specifics that wasn't included in
the data set they did a lot of targeting
so if there had been an officer-involved
shooting in a particular city they would
target that city with ads related to
following pages that had
officer-involved shootings and then if
there was a officer-involved shooting in
a different City
they would kind of like add that City on
so they would keep targeting any city
that had been that had had a
officer-involved shooting incident in
which a black man was the victim they
would continue to kind of reopened re-up
and Bree up that with ads and so there
would be ads run on anniversaries of
deaths of people who had been involved
in officer-involved shootings there were
ads for protest marches in solidarity
with other cities so they they they in
some ways the ad targeting was less
sophisticated meaning purely politically
speaking I think we would have expected
to see more in Ohio and Pennsylvania and
states that were of value in the
election and the electoral college that
wasn't really in there but the the use
of American cultural moments and
American tragedy is to continue to to
target communities that was in there
well yet to be able to be intelligent
enough to know when an anniversary is
coming up or to be able to target a
specific city that recently had it just
it's it's a limiting all of the all the
nuance and all of the solutions that we
actually want to get at because they can
just create that polarization okay so
the simple ads that promoted pages the
neck is the next one so this is the how
many total Facebook pages were
81-81 total facebook pages back the
badge being patriotic brown power and
the and these were promoted and targeted
yeah these were targeted
so for brown power they would you know
interest basis would be Mexican culture
and I think Aztec culture might have
been in there as a targeting thing back
the badges of pro-pro police page being
patriotic was just kind of right-wing
culture I don't remember off the top of
my head that if that one ran targeting I
think if in the most but they did this
it would have been sometimes it's like
people who like some of their other
pages that are that have audience
similarity sometimes it's it's it's
demographic age they did segment their
conservative pages there was some age
age based targeting in there where they
had a recognition that like younger
people might be more akin might feel
more resonance with like the snarky meme
content as opposed to the more like
Flags everywhere in Ronald Reagan kind
of content which was more of an older
generation of conservative so that was
kind of in there
and then you can see with these I don't
recall off the top of my head the dates
that these ran but at the time you can
see how many people like these are a
huge payoff at time to 500,000 for for
some of them so that's why I said I
don't know at what point in the history
this one ran if it's about two hundred
three thousand I don't know if the top
of my head remember what they wound up
getting up to quick questions and then
if Facebook gave the 81 81 Facebook
pages they believe came from IRA mmm-hmm
then they then turn around and say that
hey we know you're doing manipulations
we're gonna or they deleted the pages
before they ever dated at the Senate
okay just keep interesting the iceberg
deleted the eighty-one pages even before
they gave the date of the Senate yes Wow
Wow so then you were scraping yet data
that was yeah well I was I wasn't so
great not not scraping and the scraping
to me means actually like writing a
scraper and sure shot and
violating a term of service your analyst
I did not do that were already dead
yes Facebook and then also the all of
the twitter is three thousand seven
hundred thirty eight hundred thirty
eight hundred Twitter accounts that that
same thing happened yeah they were down
before yeah Twitter put down the thirty
hundred counts of then gave the data yes
and same process with Instagram better
later released its data and mass to the
public so the public can go and download
that data it's been it's been made
public Wow Facebook has a series of
constraints which is regular people's
pictures appear in the content and so
the house released the ads so you can go
and a couple of academic institutions
have made the ads nicely searchable
because they were released in PDF format
which is not very machine readable it's
not a very friendly way to put info on
okay this particular type of PDF is you
know the image was just kind of like
stuck in there there was no way to
extract it out but anyway the some very
patient academics did that made it
public and included all the tags for the
different ad targeting so people can go
and explore this you'll see the pictures
of people in the ads they have blacked
out faces somebody wouldn't redacted
redacted the images so there are a
couple thousand ads but there are two
hundred thousand memes so to go through
and redact out faces and the majority of
the data set hasn't been done I don't
know if it will be done I think there's
some concerns about privacy and other
things with that and then we can also
say that out of all the Facebook pages
Instagram posts to end Twitter posts and
pages that all these pages and posts
that were created they then spawned off
like a butterfly effect a bunch of other
not only the memes continuing to live on
other pages that haven't been taken down
right but this type of stuff so it's not
like it's just like oh it got all taken
down it's already made a massive yeah so
I can make I mean to get into like since
we're having a more technical
conversation in the weeds there's like
assets which is like the thing the
internet research agency controls so
they controlled the pages but then there
is just the collateral right the content
so the meme and the entire purpose of
whether it's the internet research
agency or anybody is for it to go viral
that is the entire purpose right it's to
be a unit of unit in the academic
definition is a unit of cultural
transmission it's a thing I saw you had
Dawkins book on your shelf back there so
it's a way in which we develop society
and shared cultures through these
sharing of these snippets so the entire
point is morality and so when so there
are tons of ira memes they are still
being shared today I see them all the
time on hyper-partisan main pages it
makes it really hard actually as a
researcher because you're like oh I
recognize that well if this person is
sharing an IRA meme what's the
likelihood that this account is in some
way affiliated with this operation and
you have to say you know so you you
can't make that judgment of course based
on like two or three memes because the
entire point is that it is shared
everywhere but it definitely does mean
that when you encounter this content
over and over and over and over again
you realize that people are very
receptive to it and it continues to
propagate and so we can't do analysis of
what is a likely additional IRA page
purely from the view on the outside
because the content doesn't tell you
enough and then did the platform's also
then take the preventative measures to
prevent somehow knowing if IRA was
making more pages and making more
accounts well so that's where you get at
the interesting things with the metadata
so if you create a second Twitter
account on your phone Twitter has to the
best of my knowledge some concept of
device ID right these are these are
technologies that are that exists
because of spam detection right so
platforms want to know if somebody's
creating hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of accounts on one device ID
that's probably an indication that
there's some spam thing happening right
because even if you're a media property
aware you have four or five accounts
probably you know maybe if you're an
agency you might have some special
situation but and even to my site itself
isn't even
because the device ID we've seen those
big farms yeah exactly arms click farms
and there's separate devices that all
are running separate accounts so it's
like if you can get a device for only
ten bucks now and and download the app
and make an account and just change the
global conversation with that process
times a million phones I mean we're
talking like crazy power with something
like that yes yes I just wanted him I
just wanted that's basically the yeah so
that's that's one of the challenges so
the platforms are looking more at they
can look at the content on the network
if the adversary if the you know we we
use the term aligned actor but if the
person creating the stuff is sloppy then
as we saw it because Twitter did provide
information about email addresses and
and things and their data set to the
Senate you can see them reusing email
addresses we saw on YouTube they reused
email addresses so if you know that one
email address is you know conclusively
attributed to a maligned page it's a
good indication for the platform that
they can then go and look and see was
that related to other maligned pages if
this person is an administrator for this
page and an administrator for this page
and this page is shown to be Russian
what are the or whoever Iranian now
these date anybody what can we say about
that relationship it's not always so
because this might be an unwitting dupe
who was a real American who was made an
administrator for the page or conversely
created the page and made a Russian
troll and administrator on their page
that did happen so how do we you know
this is where it's not a purely there is
no methodology of detection of ongoing
operations that doesn't involve
substantial human review you cannot tell
just based on metadata so it does get
really way down into
probabilities that something is online
and as well they improve operational
security and don't reuse email addresses
and don't you know they used Russian
beeline phones to register some of their
Twitter accounts you eventually see them
move into Google Voice right which is a
much harder thing to assess because
regular real Americans use Google Voice
all the time if you have a Russian
beeline phone tied to a Twitter account
pretending to be Baltimore City media
that's a red flag if you have a Google
Voice account tied to the same thing
that might not be a red flag yet but
this is the type of nuance that's crazy
not only is it that an individual can
happen you or I can have up to five or
however many Twitter accounts me why but
also corporations have cruder comments
organizations have Twitter accounts so
now just the sheer amount of how do you
know if it's the actual organization
themselves or someone from around the
world acting as the organization this
and how do you have the proper
algorithms that sense these types of
things and what is the proper course of
action these are the tough tough
questions alright let's go on to the top
performers on Facebook by timing of
posts by page so this kind of shows you
over time from 2014 from the end of 2014
until 2017 and 2017
yeah we were interested I know this is
an eye chart Jonathan Albright made this
we were interested in what topics they
considered worth starting pages over
over time and we were interested in did
they create the page when the issue
became a thing so to speak or did they
create the page in anticipation did they
repurpose the page you know what what
were they doing
and so rm8 which is the furthest most
left one that was actually a travel page
that was just kind of like Millennials
talking about travel there are things
that we know so this is it again
Facebook is an interesting case because
Facebook provided data starting in early
2015 I think with our m8 they gave us
some stuff from 2014 but we know that
they were operating pages on Facebook
prior to that because Adrienne Chen of
New York wrote an excellent piece called
the agency in the New York Times
magazine where he alludes to other pages
that they were running on celebrity
culture and so Facebook provided to the
Senate starting January 1st 2015 and so
some of that old stuff doesn't appear
but what you see is like being patriotic
so basic patriotism LGBT United they
were early on their heart of Texas they
get to secession in 2015 and you start
to see as things like narratives about
Confederate monuments heat up those
pages turn on the ways in which like the
meme the mean content comes a little bit
later that sort of stuff so the you we
wanted to see what you could get at
regarding what they saw as early
American issues versus later American
issues if that makes sense yes yes and
the why is is the page in the exes time
no I'm sorry to disturb you yeah the why
is the page and then yeah so it's like
when did they come up how often do they
look through this and learn about you
know I copied and pasted that thing
because that was a whole section where
the y-axis did represent time for a lot
of it thank you
so then yes so then understanding states
and then the next one is another really
good visual the comparative engagement
on facebook these are the top 20
accounts yeah so you can see in this top
area the account that got the most likes
was being patriotic got 6.3 million
likes the one that got the most comments
was to stop all invaders account which
got seven hundred seventy three thousand
comments black tifus got the most
reactions at one point three million
reactions heart of Texas got the most
shares at almost 5 million shares and
this was over from 2015 2018 yep so we
were interested in with when we when we
did these kinds of things we were
curious about guys are so much stuff
actually so we looked at we were trying
to get a sense of what audiences the
content resonated with and what were
their big hits so this as it
the top 20 accounts if you look at also
in the deck somewhere is all across all
81 of the accounts and you see this huge
longtail where you have extraordinary
engagement in the top 20 so this looks
like you know low but even here you see
the pretty substantial drop off between
the the kind of the cluster where they
really like hit and it was successful
versus the rest we follow anybody so
with this this is still you know half a
million to a million
would you still reactions I think in
this yeah but like the other 61 accounts
have barely right yeah right so there
are a lot of failures and and what you
see there is like throw things at the
wall and see what sticks so we tried to
caveat everything to the greatest extent
possible with how do you properly
contextualize this in the mainstream
media environment so what you'll hear a
lot is overall relative to the entire
sum total of election related content
these numbers are small that is
absolutely true
another thing that you know that you'll
hear is Fox News gets 10x this you know
10x the engagement on any given post and
that is also true what's interesting is
we looked at the ways in which they
segmented their audiences down extremely
small and then they pretended to be
those people so the so it's not so much
Fox News or CNN or whatever you know
ivory tower media behemoth telling you
something
it's your fellow Texas secessionist
communicating with you your fellow LGBT
person communicating with you and so the
posts and the content on the page is
really about building up communities
around these are people like us and so
given that one the you know I I have
felt that using as a denominator the sum
total of every post on Facebook of
course this is tiny relative to that
absolutely but what I think is a
cessation of identity exactly is when is
when you are targeting something not as
a media property but as a fellow you
know fellow American
or as a fellow American who
fundamentally distrusts the media and is
saying we can't trust what mainstream
media is telling us we have to be
thinking independently and so you see as
a theme throughout particularly like
black Thomas it was I didn't trust the
media so I became it you know basically
saying the media doesn't tell our
stories so we're going to tell our own
stories and so we're gonna build up a
community of people telling our own
stories and so this is where you get at
that is a sentiment that resonates with
many Americans so what they're doing is
they're capitalizing on that erosion of
trust they're capitalizing on that
ability to create tribes and then
they're going in that way so that's the
more interesting I think think to assess
when we look at this operation not did
it achieve 10% of the total engagements
of election-related content which is
just never going to happen and uh you
know Sally yeah I want to hit on the
next visualization is also you call
these the jaw breakers Jonathan operate
those great visualizations he's that
he's a professor at Columbia tau
journalism school and is our jawbreaker
so some of the reasons for doing these
is actually just part of the exploratory
process right which is when you ask a
question sometimes visualizing something
helps insights pop out what we were
looking at with the the jawbreakers so
each ring each colored ring is one page
and then the circles in them are sized
according to reach of the post and so we
were very interested in the breakout
posts the kind of like you know total
interactions and things like that and so
we were so that was that was more
function of what we were looking at here
yeah the size so each color is a page
and that each the size is the the post
that went almost viral yeah bigger yeah
okay cool cool I love these
visualizations and then the next one is
kind of some of the memes that were
propagated about saying things like
like Facebook's like that's a nice
opinion you have there surety censorship
I know if that was yeah they were really
on that early right so it's March 2017
the idea that Facebook moderating
Russian troll pages was tyranny and
censorship that narrative is not
uncommon again right the idea that
Facebook is persecuting our community by
taking down our content but you could
argue that that's an extremely
mainstream view right now correct right
yeah yeah
so there you have it in March 2017 they
were really cranky about about getting
moderated and triggers that inflammatory
response of that Oh our community is
yeah Facebook is full of liberal
fascists and domestic terrorists
moderating our page Wow
yeah how that's very partisan and very
inflammatory and yeah then not nuanced
at all yeah and an increasingly
mainstream opinion yeah yeah and then
the next one is we transitioned a little
bit to Instagram mm-hmm okay so then
here are some of the opposition to
Hillary's candidacy yeah they had an
Instagram account that was focused on
feminism and social justice it did not
have a parallel Facebook page so a lot
of the Instagram accounts also had
Facebook pages as you would expect if
you're running a media property you know
you're all over the Internet
feminism tag appeared to simply go into
the feminism hashtag gather content from
there and repurpose it and that was most
most of the account did not seem to be
producing original content it was just
their attempt to create a feminism
focused social justice intersectionality
kind of page and they used it mostly to
erode support for Hillary Clinton among
feminists that was the point Josh and
it's just the repurposing is crazy did
you guys did you guys ever at all laugh
when you were this is not about it this
is not an intellectual exercise this is
an emotional exercise right and if you
as a researcher can't recognize that
this stuff works and resonates on an
emotional level then I don't think you
understand like you know as a human that
propaganda works and and that's a that's
a thing where I can sit there and I can
quote for you the number of likes and
tweets and this amount the other thing
but ultimately this is about producing
content that emotionally resonates with
people bolstered by the signal of all of
the likes and retweets because that
reinforces to just as you know are a
heuristic that it's a thing worth paying
attention to so it makes sense yeah but
really no I mean I laughed at the
right-wing ones I laughed at the
left-wing ones they were the left-wing
ones like the humor fell flat a lot of
the time it actually wasn't very good
and I'm gonna point out it might be
because I don't mean you know when it's
interesting that there's a there's even
a bit in here that that is spelled a
specific way I mean I'll point it out
later but that you can tell that it
actually has a little bit of that
Russian misspelling and the next one is
the top performer on Instagram oh yeah
this is the one we talked about a little
bit earlier yeah so this is again so
Instagram is interesting you can't
really do a one to one comparison
because Instagram only has two types of
engagements it has comments and likes
versus Facebook which has the react G
and the shares but that said this was
the most popular I had the most
engagements of the two types available
on Instagram this is the different skin
colors of legs in the white paper I
believe I did go and track down the name
of the shoe company that produced this
this is an ad for those shoes mm-hmm
and so you'll see they put the at blacks
to Gram underscore underscore that was
the name of the Instagram account of
course in the original image like that
doesn't yeah correct yeah yeah so one
thing I wanted to do but it wasn't sure
like I didn't have time but I was
curious like you know reaching out to
some of the people who were targeted hey
your image was appropriated in this way
what do you think of it yeah I think
that's something that you know I was
curious what you know what what people
thought when they were appropriated in
that way yeah correct I did wind up
having a Twitter interaction with the
gentleman behind the the real advocacy
organization black guns matter which the
IRA created a fake page you know of
entire Wow
yeah so so there they did they liberally
stole things from brands small
businesses and other entities and it was
hard to you know as you're tracing back
the original content you're wondering
like did they actually reach out and ask
permission to what extent people know
who they were dealing with
they were just masquerading as a black
media advocacy organization with a big
following so you would think if somebody
such as that reached out to you and said
can I use your image to tell our you
know to tell our cultural story or
shared our shared values that people
would be receptive to that and that's I
think where things continued ahead and
that's a that's a that's a challenge
there's so many variations someone can
make a fan page that's positive someone
can make a anti this page but then when
you kind of act as that page without
even talking and asking for that pages
permission and you're trying to like
feel they're like all that type of stuff
this is where you can get a little scary
as well I want to hit this this is the
comparative engagement Instagram total
engagement yeah again you see that like
that pretty sharp drop-off on Instagram
they were more successful in terms of
audience growth and engagement with the
black community on Facebook it was more
successful with the conservative
targeted pages
yeah so feminism tag is number four on
there so you can't see that they did a
little bit of a better job but yeah at
blacks liberal Hagelin always kind of
appears somewhere down you know the very
end of the top of the top 20 28 million
total interactions on blacks graham ET a
million on american veteran octagram i
think objectively showed up in a number
of you know as we were trying to a
friend of mine we had a whole bunch of
conversations because he was much more
of a skeptic that this could have had
any impact and he went and ran the
numbers looking at some of these
accounts relative to authentic media and
did find that that one kind of made it
into the top 10 or top 20 of instagram
accounts you know top 10 or 20 well
targeting sorry targeting that community
o targeting at that time at that time
discarded we've been trying to figure
out what we're gonna use to extrapolate
out from that like what was an objective
success relative to the mainstream real
american media operation that kind of
that research is scope that's going on
yeah yeah okay and then here's this
similar mosaic that you made mm-hm and
then this one is for all beautiful
visualizations are credit jonathan
albright this is yep this is the
hundreds of 833 Instagram accounts and
this was just service sized by follower
account 133 instruments okay 81 Facebook
pages 3800 Twitter accounts okay okay
and this is by side so you can tell the
black scam the ones in the center are
kept on your account and then here's the
mosaic again the next jaw breakers the
jawbreaker mosaic yeah yeah yeah and
then you can tell that there's the big
there are a little bit yeah they're not
as there are a lot more posts
no is this more evenly distributed I
think okay and then the next one is the
media Mirage wow that was a yeah that
was a real so the way that this came to
be so if you want to ascertain whether
something points to something else
you've got either they shout out the
name of the page in the text or they
have the brand mark in the image and so
looking at a combination of
the post is owned by okay let me let me
walk through this so in this particular
case you have pan-african routes move
which is a square and the squares are
Facebook pages and the arrow is going
this direction which means it shares
content from the page black excellence
so we were saying that had African roots
move was pointing people to black
excellence which is another one of their
pages encouraging people to go pay
attention to the content on black
excellence so this was looking at well
from the Facebook pages this was a real
challenge to do and I know it's like
hideously ugly because the high
centrality accounts in this particular
case were you know we're sharing out to
the majority of the community and in
turn sharing sharing back to but what
this was showing was ways in which the
cloud shaped things were things that
they did not own and the logs were not
owned right the clouds were not only by
them swears in the parallelograms or
yeah this is something that I think at
some point needs to be redone by an
[Laughter]
argument actually where I just you know
I was like all right how do i how do I
convey as we were as we were thinking
about like ways in which they were
internet working their pages both with
real authentic black media and again
then I would sit there and I would run
down all of these because if you look at
something where they're tagging in some
of these pages so repetitively the
question becomes is that also their page
right and so that's where you get at
which you know how do you know if the
page is still up that presumably to me
meant that Facebook had looked at it and
decided it got to stay up some of the
pages like this one 17th soulja for its
a that was an Instagram account actually
did disappear it's it's not there
anymore
it was never announced as internet
research agency but it no longer
and there are a couple more in there but
there are definitely some where you just
look at it and you try to figure out
like what am i you know what am I
looking at is this real so they can mate
they can make a post that then redirects
people to another page they have been
tagged a bunch of other pages some real
some very exactly so then you can move
people to different yeah this is this is
a complicated problem this took me a
couple weeks I'm just going so we had
the the summary stats are largely run by
query the the again the the cleaning of
the data is somewhat manual the in terms
of like you've got to look at over a
bunch times you got to come up the
schema after that you can do summary
stats relatively quickly looking at this
you've got the image again the image
recognition that the clustering that can
tell you some stuff the text that can
tell you some stuff but because this was
such a sensitive topic we did I did go
through all of these manually and so I
went through every single on there about
67,000 Facebook memes and I just sat
there going through them one after
another after another because also you
want to understand like what are you
missing what should the what should the
aughtta
what should the algorithmic analysis
have conveyed to you that perhaps it did
not or what do you as a human learn from
doing this analysis that a computer does
not and and so you know how does that
inform development of technology for
this purpose over time you know in the
future and things like that so this was
this was unfortunately painstakingly
manual that's the problem right which is
sitting there and you're staring at the
stuff and so you're like
how you know the the overall core
takeaway is 100% solid I hope to god my
arrows are solid this is where another
thought about this that is so crazy is
that this is what we were talking about
all together before we went live was the
need for critical thinking and so if you
are a real account if you are a cloud
here you're a real account and you see a
piece of content come from an idea from
anything that seems to be just one of
those fake farm accounts that then you
can't immediately just be trigger to
want to just reshare that content but to
be able to like double click in identify
who that account actually is where
they're from
are they real can I go to their URL do
they actually have clients or customers
or omission is a clothing store with
something like that you can kind of run
down you go to the website does it have
an address where is the address
does it appear to actually be shipping
clothing are there pictures on the
Instagram of people who appear to be
real people wearing the clothing yes so
you do wind up in these very human
investigative processes my assumption is
that that's what's happening within the
tech platforms as well that we use a
combination of algorithms to flag things
but then that's not enough then it
becomes a a researcher process and then
you of course don't want to have just
one researcher do it because that could
be biased that could be this either it
could be mistakes made so that's when
you get at to what extent can we
replicate this algorithmically generate
net work maps using and if you included
some of my other network maps yeah we
have some some of the other ones are
purely algorithmically generated this
one was you know both done by algorithm
and then done by people um and that's
why it's ugly and then the next one is
the Facebook person program stats in
total yeah ooh I'm gonna get you more
water no I think I'm okay sorry it's
allergies in San Francisco
no don't I can't okay so the Facebook
versus Instagram stats yeah okay the
total amount of likes on Facebook up 37
thousand there's a million excuse me
yeah on Instagram 183 million likes mmm
total amount to shares on Facebook 30
million shares
so total interactions and the hundreds
of millions across both platforms
yeah and followers and the millions also
we worked just curious about Instagram
wasn't getting talked about in the news
very much
Facebook was and so as we had this set
of Instagram data we wanted to look at
what was instagrams role how valuable
did they think was Instagram like a
second-class citizen where they were
like no it's all about Facebook no it
turned out Instagram was very much a
core priority yeah and they did get
significant solid engagement on
Instagram as well yep yep okay and then
the next one is ad spending on Facebook
and Instagram and this is per target
landing page so in rubles it's about 70
rubles as a dollar ish something like
that yeah I I went and dredged up I
think it was in the 60s in 2016 okay
yeah yeah in then and then it's
something around about on the high
spends was 10,000 that was across the
black matters properties across the
black my she was about a couple thousand
further and I spend perfect this is
again with this we were interested in
click-through rate we were interested in
cost per click we were interested in
were they directing people to outside
landing pages like URLs were they
directing them to Facebook pages or
Instagram accounts the ads were such a
small part of the operation it was you
use the ads as a means to an end so the
ads get talked about a lot especially
because this is where you get that it
was only a hundred thousand dollars and
you know millions were spent on ads in
the election yes that's true
the way that we think about ads though
is ads direct people to your page once
people are on your page you have them as
a receptive audience and you can
continue to engage with them over time
and so and the interest of summary stats
you know worked through all the ads as
well yep and then and then the next one
is just ads by spend as well so then
this was a per ad copy how many
impressions what was the click-through
rate what was to spend there and so we
kind of mentioned that yeah 67 rubles
for a dollar that's 1649 us dos spent on
the high spent ad yeah they were not
they were not I mean then to put that in
context 1600 bucks on an ad is not a lot
of money but then like you said when
they land on the page what happens how
much is overwhelmed by that and how much
do they end up being digging deep right
yeah and their click-through rates were
good and that's even it's a good
click-through rate yeah like five
percent to thirty right so you run ads
right holy cow
damn so in that and the high
click-through rates are likely because
it is such a it's good to arising yeah
post yeah the more polarizing the more
click Beatty etc so we got a really
really dark social fabric away from
towards the nuance all right let's hit
Twitter so the next one
Ronnie is our Twitter and so this one is
just an example of one of the posts that
was on yeah yes and this is okay so this
came out of the white paper oh gosh what
um that was yeah so the the tweets were
I am trying to remember why I included
this one honestly or why you picked this
one is this because it was me I picked
this one because it was such an
Instagram to tweet was what they did
there that's that I believe I'm 99% sure
that's a baby tweet yeah because this is
the poster wall correct yes I am trying
to remember
why I think this was um oh this was the
Russians talking about how Donald Trump
jr. had every right to meet with a
Russian lawyer yeah this is like the
comparison is also kind of like in a
sense like just that I thought I
included this because I thought that it
was kind of one of those like oh if you
think this is not okay but you think
this is oh so what about ISM yeah the
what about ISM was there but but it also
I think I probably included it
originally because I was trying to grab
examples there were a couple of
interesting things here first the
English is so fascinating to me because
I studied Russian in college for a
number of years and just the as somebody
who took a second language later in life
one of the things I always wondered was
do I speak in any way like a normal
speaker speaks and the answer is almost
certainly not right you you sound like
you're like you know kind of educated
after the fact and so this is like a
nuanced argument structured and an
extremely like here's my declarative
statement at the top here are my three
supporting points here's my closing
cents at the bottom and so you see these
like first of all secondly third of all
moreover they loved moreover that always
a bet appeared in so many of these posts
I mean well this is like a post
pretending to be I don't unfortunately
member off the top of my head which one
this this came from but this is
supposedly the words of a red pilled
American communicating you know in in
like proper essay format about why it's
totally cool that Donald Trump met with
Russian lawyers and every now and then
there were these like absurd moments
where you know they would write these
you see them actually kind of move away
from long-form English because there are
tells there tells yeah and so you see
now shorter shorter or more
interestingly one of the things I
wondered about was some of the stuff in
the data set just on the text just as
you read the text this is again where
human has a different experience of text
than a machine right I was reading it
and I was saying machines I'm sure can
can calculate fluency metrics and things
we didn't bother with that but some
Postum like god this is just straight-up
colloquial American English and so I
would type that stuff into a search
engine and it would usually return a
cribbed post from somewhere else so
sometimes I was like local news and so
there would be some obscure local news
site and so they would grab the local
news like the lead and then they would
use the lead over unrelated meme because
then you're you're kind of breaking that
the tell of yeah yeah yeah okay and then
the next one is the Twitter bot
coordination over time okay yeah so so
here you had out again on now you have
on the y-axis great access right in this
one Twitter user number out of the 3800
yes and then the amount of green that
you see is the amount of posts that
they're making over time yeah we were we
were actually looking we were looking
just at like I said we didn't spend as
much time on Twitter as as our as our
other counterpart team did looking at
automation and these are basically
accounts tweeting oh damn that is yeah
that was the point of this was actually
just to look at what did the ampulla you
know could we assess whether they had
amplifier bots in addition to sock
puppet BOTS and it's so so the
difference yeah how do you think about
personas on Twitter some of the and the
intention of a persona account is to
engage directly one-on-one other
accounts are just there to to get those
likes and retweet numbers up yeah so
okay and then the next one is the top
individual performing content on Twitter
and so this was retweeted over a hundred
thousand times the top photo in the yep
inspirational news stories inspirational
histories and related to
there were a lot of inspirational
stories about the young man's they are
there yeah exactly
no and that's the that's where you get
at the idea that well it's more how do
we engender feelings of pride and make
people want to amplify you know people
will amplify positive stories even on so
if you're growing an audience and you
want to do it without ads one of the
ways that you do that is you create
engaging content people amplify it and
then their friends see it for free right
so you use your audience to beget more
of an audience without having to pay for
it and so what you see is a lot of
inspirational stories particularly among
the pages that we're targeting the black
community about inspirational stories
that the media won't show you and so
it'll say like and share like and share
like and share like so that the world
knows about and then the name of the
person and I did go back and Google for
some of these stories you know make sure
they're real yeah see how the mainstream
media reported on them see if the
mainstream media reported on them try to
ascertain like where they got this stuff
from and it's you know it it's
legitimate stuff these are all
legitimate feelings that people have of
course what they're doing it for is to
grow their audiences because as you
amass your audience you have more people
that you can influence a little so you
take your page and while your pages
let's say positive 75 80 percent of the
time they're going to be times when you
want to activate your audience so and so
you grow your audience just through
sometimes engaging stories and the black
community it was a lot of engaging in
very positive stories on the right
landing pages it was very angry stories
so it was stories of like share how this
veteran has gotten screwed share how
this veteran is not getting resources
but this immigrant is the police the pro
police pages though again you would see
these you know amazing stories of
bravery okay
right beautiful police dog like and
share boom goes viral right because
people share things that make them have
feelings they don't share you know
chronological assessments about the
legality of Donald Trump meeting a
Russian lawyer that post isn't going to
go anywhere but posts about look at this
inspirational kid or this inspirational
dog or this hero there is still a part
of us that wants those stories damn you
can scrape you can you can parse for the
most popular content and then amplify
that act to like build your audience
that way and then you can embed kind of
the ones that you want to kind of
parasitically wanna make the horrible
influences maxilla this is some crazy
stuff that you can get that you can
build the BOTS to do okay so this is the
hashtags of linked communities this is
one of them oh yeah this is well visual
thank you because the human didn't do it
I didn't make that I didn't sit there
drawing arrows and writing stuff in this
one as you can tell that's that's
because this is is just a hashtag
analysis and and this is purely
text-based so we are not looking at we
can we can position so the I know that
people probably will be able to see this
but there are red dots and there are
blue dots wrong we'll zoom in a bit okay
so red dots are the names of their
accounts and then blue dots are the
hashtags that they were using so we did
try to at least position pages within
the within the cloud classic so you can
see the illegal immigration was a page
well it's always hard to visualize
massive quantities of Liberty risings a
page right using that takes funny it's
the funny yes and so what you see if you
if you angle down here drunk the bottom
left or the cop block stuff left left
the update yes okay so this is where you
see things like police
you know how ways in which police kind
of unifies the pro so they're using the
hash tag police for the pro police stuff
and then also for the black lives matter
and so if you were just on Instagram one
of the ways that people consume on
Instagram rather than just following
accounts some people follow hashtags
yeah and so if you follow a hashtag you
can create feelings of tension depending
on what you're pushing into the hashtag
so if one person is following hashtag
police because they're the wife of a
police officer and if one person is
following hashtag police because they're
part of a community that's had like
issues with officer-involved shootings
you're having a very different
experience when you go into that with
with why you're looking for that hashtag
and so there is an opportunity at that
point to create some of the the tension
and the more direct conflict by pushing
opposing content into the same hashtag
and so that's what you see when you look
at the hashtag analysis we were looking
at so we need to make memes of nuance
and push them into the tags that are
being looked at by both parties I'll try
to think of the solutions or a day I
know I know yeah the nuanced meme
culture yes yeah okay so the
visualization here I like that point
that you can see if you look at a tag
that you can see both the sides being
exasperate under one tag and then let's
go to now we're gonna switch from the
Twitter activity to YouTube activity
which was crazy when I saw this that out
of the 1,100 is pieces of content that
like 90% plus were for black meeting it
was like police violence that's yeah
analyzing YouTube data stuff so first of
all we just did basic summary stats for
a lot of this looking at the we had
channel titles we had video titles and
the way the videos so there was no
metadata so I don't have any engagement
stats to discuss on this YouTube just
simply didn't provide it it was not
given to us so we couldn't analyze it
but yeah it was overwhelmingly focused
on black Americans and then Pinterest it
was another platform yeah so that wasn't
given to [ __ ] that was something that I
had found
when I was looking for okay so back in
2017 the first conversations about
election interference were actually
related to fake news and fake news meant
literally news that was free meaning
Pope endorses Donald Trump megyn kelly
fired from Fox News Hillary Clinton dead
of pneumonia body double put in her
place right so just blatantly false BS
that was the original conversation about
what happened in election 2016 and that
conversation happened in 2017 in around
June 2017 media organizations I think it
might have been think progress it might
have been Media Matters broke the first
story that one of the largest black
lives matter pages on face book was
believed to be a Russian troll page and
we had had a sense that there were we
knew that there were fake Russian pages
Adrienne Chen had identified that back
in 2015 the fact that they had been
deployed in the context of the u.s.
election was not really widely
understood until mid 2017 and at the
time I feel recall there was this
adversarial relationship almost with the
platforms where there was still very
much this idea that like fake news
couldn't have influenced an election the
Russian Bop problem is overstated so
those of us who are on the outside we're
actually trying to find their content so
we could see what it really looked like
and there was this kind of breakthrough
where Jonathan Albright found a crowd
tangle which is an analytics platform
for looking at how information spreads
and really began to get a sense of like
what the pages were and how they had
operated and once we had the names of
the pages those of us who were
interested in finding this content
because the platforms had already taken
it down by this point we're going and
where we're trying to suss it out and I
found some on Pinterest and I found the
the United Muslims page content they had
made a Pinterest board for it and
they've made Pinterest boards for a
couple of them they weren't trying to
share the content on Pinterest they were
using Pinterest almost as like a file
like a file cabinet for the memes just
like you know kind of get it in there at
least I assume that's why it was there
it was just kind of limited to a board
and
and this account had a few different
boards and so we were able to to find
some of the stuff and the purpose of
including this was to show that it was
bigger than the big three tech platforms
yep and then reddit is the next one yeah
then there is use on reddit as well
reddit was so fantastic in the sense
that they chose to leave it all up there
so they left everything everything is
still like it was her not live
everything is um if you go to that link
with a special post yeah you'll see
Steve's posts talking about the 944
accounts they found and you can actually
still go and you can see the posts and
so he so reddit does their own analysis
showing that these were where most of
the stuff was posted and there is you
can also go in and you can see the tour
even you can see the karma the Karma
scores for the accounts David Clarke's
worth just the fact that it was left up
the 944 counts with the boom post the
fact that it was left yeah I think it's
because there wasn't much personal data
in there so they didn't have the same
constraints that Facebook and it's
there's no pictures of people's faces
yeah and the next one is tumblr so then
tumblers and other platform activity
yeah and the tumblr did the same thing
they made up they made a source or sort
of similar to Reddit they put up a
transparency report where they disclosed
so this information was not provided to
the Senate it was just kind of put out
to the world and yeah there were these I
don't shoot us was related to do not
shoot us which was a web site which was
related to another account called hands
up don't shoot so there again there
networking there brands across the
internet and yeah this was wow what an
extensive campaign name your Pokemon
with the u.s. police brutality victim's
name find a gym near the crime scene
capture make a screenshot of your
Pokemon owning the gym email it to us
and win Amazon giftcards ok the
recycling of top-performing
pages is also the next slide and so on
this one we have things like the
repurposing of content that gets viral
and this was the army of Jesus
Paige and the like a few beliefs keep
scrolling if you do oh yeah they loved
this image they used it three or four
times and they had another one with a
slightly different looking Jesus they
just well because again it's like if you
believe if you like you're reinforcing
that you're reinforcing your engagement
with the page in the account which means
that the algorithm they're either you're
ranked either so it was the the
algorithms are like determined they're
they're determining what you see and so
if you're engaging with an Instagram
account it's gonna show you more memes
from that Instagram account in your feed
you're just communicating to the
algorithm that you want to see more
stuff so yeah so on Facebook liking
something pushes it into your friends
feed on Instagram liking stuff signals
that that they should they should you
know that they should show you more from
that account this is that butterfly
effect you're teaching the algorithm
yeah you're teaching an algorithm and
you don't know which feeds it's going
into affright yours um the next one is
the rebranding names across pages yeah
so we talked this is the kind of stuff
that comes out of image clustering it's
crazy that you just just changed the
logo yeah paging I know yeah and just
like that you you're hitting the masses
more easily yeah okay and then next is
the this was crazy
I just want spend a look yeah this is
the thing reap you can reap hurt you can
build an audience kind of like we were
saying earlier you can build an audience
with content that people like like like
an awesome you can be like with Jesus
yeah yeah we're Texas rich which is such
a remarkable like cultural gap here in
that people who want women are like
bacon are not the audience that I would
assume to seamlessly transition into
Jesus memes but what do I know you know
maybe they had some drop-off there but
what I do want to highlight with this
though is um the if you look now
Facebook will show you that pages pages
that have been renamed for just this
just just this purpose right yeah so
I don't know that they do it on
Instagram on Facebook so facebook now
has page transparency features that are
partly a result of Wow we fallout from
this from this operation which is to say
like you used to not know that the
Bernie Sanders meme page you're
following used to be you know a Kermit
the Frog page or whatever right or like
something else that was um you know kind
of audience hacked to get to a certain
size yeah and then again that certain
size conveys a sense of credibility a
sense of quality and then they turn it
to something else and yeah so it was
this was this was the weirdest thing
though I got the data set and like I so
I said I explained the whole cleaning
thing so I'll say this here but the so
I'm looking at the image number so all
of the posts are indexed and so I'm
looking at the number that matches the
text content
it says army of Jesus then I'm looking
at this there were some like seriously
raunchy Kermit memes and I was like what
is going on my first thought was I was
like did we screw something so I'm going
back to the original source you know the
original CSV file is trying to figure
out why this is and it's real this may
be a tactic that's used more in the
future which isn't crazy to repurposing
but also doing things like e-commerce
selling merchandise also running things
like a digital marketing shop the next
asset Ron is doing things like promoting
people to get involved in the causes
stickers the stickers really blew me
away like those are really good stickers
they're cute
they're it's little Panthers they were
made by a pretend account named Melanie
Panther and Melanie Panther was a
consultant for black matters and so they
touted her work and I think you could I
could still find these available for
download when I was doing this project I
don't know if they're if they're down
yet
and then the next asset also shows the
direct outreach always be recruiting so
this was a
recruiting to the page yeah so we've
talked a ton about the social media
operation but ultimately if you want to
like create you know create tension on
the next level you drive people into the
streets and so there are about 81
different events that push people into
the streets and literally Facebook
events and you know some of them were
their own events that they created some
of them were events that they amplified
and so many of the events were protests
and they wanted people to go and to
document the protests also so there
would be so these are everything from
like come create content for us come
design for us and then you would see hey
can you go photograph our protest can
you go YouTube or you know livestream
our protest and so they're they're
bringing in real people to to act as
vectors both for you know kind of in
street action and then also people to
document in-stream action it's
interesting if you think about it in the
context of like pseudo events you know
the idea that there are events that are
created wholly for media consumption and
and the way that they're using that
capability to capability to leverage
online communities to create real world
discord to document it so that they can
then like make hay of it back online and
that is a very interesting cycle to look
at as we think about yes yes how
real-world in an online world propaganda
a bot can make you go into the streets
and go and do something and then
videotape it representing that BOTS
organization and then put it on your
accounts and it's a crazy cycle now um
okay and I just want to quickly mention
there did you guys use optical character
recognition yeah well I'll say that Oh
Sara's not it doesn't always yield
particularly meaningful results which
was one of the reasons why I went
through and did so much manual review
it's just it's hard to get good data out
of it and we did it and we similarly
chunked the YouTube videos into stills
and tried to see what was worth
extracting from that yeah I mean you
know you you try all manner of
exploratory analyses to decide what's
worth doing turned out the OCR data
wasn't very useful wasn't very useful
but we tried interesting and then the
the mimetic propagation in the impacts
like the mimetic spread I like how you
call this on the three words were
propagation persistence and impact that
is a DARPA framework and so that link
goes to a DARPA paper on persistence
propagation and impact I I wanted to try
to both credit obviously prior art but
also explain how research done from 2012
to 2015 on social media manipulation
propaganda that those frameworks that we
were thinking about in 2012 did kind of
manifest in reality and so how do you
know both from the standpoint of what
should we have learned and also what did
we learn and how do we tie that
knowledge base back to to where we are
today yeah so that paper is fantastic I
mean I highly recommend reading and I'm
pretty sure it links to a slide deck I
think I'll link to the slide deck just
so that people could go through and
understand persistence propagation and
impact our persistence when we talk in
terms of a meme it's like does the image
have staying power propagation is how
far does it go how do people evolve it
and and spread it and then impact is
that's the hardest thing to quantify
always but it's does the community begin
to absorb the meme like what impact does
the meme have on the community in this
case the images here are from what I
believe to be a real person just running
a extremely small black media page and
during the time period during which this
operation was happening this page
flagged for us in part because we were
trying to find these images Oscar on the
Internet
and realizing that this person had
pulled from three different internet
research agency accounts and we shared
them and that was very interesting to me
because it does show this is again an N
of one but it shows that for at least
some people who operate their own pages
which have their own audiences they did
go they did take that content and they
were clearly following multiple pages so
that whole interwoven mess diagram that
we talked about earlier that is exactly
what the purpose of doing that was right
and so here this page really threw me
for a loop where I was like I'm pretty
true this as a real person I'm pretty
sure this is not Russian I don't know
for sure but and yet here it is
incorporating ideas and incorporating
collateral from not one but three
different pages in a relatively short
period of time so it's interesting to
think you know a lot of the questions
about impact is like did it swing the
election I think the more interesting
questions about impactor how is it
internalized and how does it transform
the way we think about ourselves in our
communities in our country yep yep and
then the posts about the in-group
identity we've touched on this here are
just some more examples I'm trying to
make America believe again ignore for
Satan team like for Jesus team I mean
thing which isn't great there yeah yeah
correct stuff like that the suppression
narratives is the next one I won't vote
will you yeah there's a lot of that with
her thanks for the vote team yeah so so
the operation became very political late
2015 when the Republican primary was
heating up and then of course with the
general election and again the
overwhelming majority of it was to a
road support for Hillary Clinton among
communities that would have been
inclined to vote for her such as you
know traditionally speaking the black
community and and women and feminists
yeah and then to not do not vote for
oppressors I mean there's some crazy
stuff in here um this is one I just want
to highlight quickly is that being
patriotic if you look at some of these
memes you can start telling maybe in the
go to the bottom right or sorry a middle
right Ron he's
to the middle-right you can see what
this is the last year of Obama's
presidency like and share if then makes
you happy and so that's a classic slip
in an accent
with Russia in the u.s. yeah that versus
Dan there's there's a I don't want to go
into all the towels because like we yeah
it's because a lot of them still tell
but but there is yeah this was this was
like the during the primaries they were
adamantly pro-trump they liked mark are
they liked Rand Paul for like a hot
second and before moving to Trump but
this was just looking at how political
narratives clustered and yeah yep and
then what we can also try and uncover
what why right why the pro Trump you
know what's the reason why the next
one's heart of Texas which you mentioned
the beginning oh this is yeah this was
just actually just from like a
clustering standpoint we were looking at
flags and flags and state images yeah
and what's crazy about this is that to
do something like at exit or Cal exit
right California Exeter Texas exit is a
massive crazy thing that like you think
rapist movements yes that's how you
start the crumbling of of the world
division division and crumbly promoting
Chris conspiracies is the next one who
killed Seth rich also this is not
Hillary Clinton where's that's an
excellent on II who killed Seth rich and
this is not Larry Clinton where is the
real one things like this and then yeah
we talked about that that's the yeah I
didn't believe the media so I became one
and then that last one on the left is
targeted to the left yeah I think I've
got something that people do need to
understand there's a lot of a lot of the
idea that things like media erosion
target right-wing audiences but no no
they did it for everyone it was everyone
the idea that you cannot trust the
mainstream media you cannot you know see
even liberals the L with a bird on it
was a page called born liberal the
people will believe what the media tells
them they believe
Antenor well this is so even stuff like
this can just
terior ate like you said in general the
belief in media yeah but at the same
time and kind of that same culture of
the calling everything fake news its
what is real who do we trust to deliver
us a real truth and this has become a
main thing that we converse about then
the next one is about disparaging CNN
CNN got special attention on the right
landing pages but I mean this again is
um it's it's a this is like a chicken
egg thing right I mean they're just
taking the narrative that is actually
really out there and amplifying
amplifying amplifying and then the this
one was the ire the IRA socializing
WikiLeaks that was really interesting we
get a lot of okay so for anyone so the
so as I mentioned I was not in any way
asked to look at the idea of collusion
that is purely a that was a Miller
investigation not not not part of my
role with Senate Intelligence Committee
at all so but there was this hack &
league operation that happened and if
you go and you look at the molar report
gets a whole treatment the first section
in the report is internet research
agency of which much is redacted because
a lot of those folks are indicted now
the second page is a sorry the second
section is this assessment of the GRU so
the internet research agency is a social
media agency that is not an official
part of the Russian government the GRU
is it is Russian military intelligence
so it's kind of the equivalent of the
American Defense Intelligence Agency
what what happened is they hacked the
Democratic the the DNC and they hacked
the Clinton campaign so two separate
hacks and then using the gucchy for
persona and the DC leaks persona they
leaked this information and it's kind of
laundered through WikiLeaks and other
you know other means of getting the
information out to the public that
potentially above all was I think in
some ways phenomenally impactful because
those leaked emails became the story
yeah and so they time them for things
like immediately following
you know immediately following press
moments that were not so great for
Donald Trump but they also did this
socialization where you know how do you
bolster support for WikiLeaks how do you
reiterate that Julian Assange is a noble
freedom fighter that WikiLeaks is you
know a you know a staunch defender of
freedom and how do you make people trust
that cache of documents and so what you
see is leading into the internet route
to the to those dumps these posts come
out sort of socializing the idea of
Assange as a as a great guy and these
documents is you know very important and
it's interesting because we don't know
we still don't know to what extent those
two operations were connected so all we
have is what you can dismiss as
coincidental if you're so inclined but
what we do have is these posts in which
they are stating you know bolstering
support for first lines when they do it
in the black community the left-leaning
community on the right community so
there were certain narratives that go
out uniformly to all American targets so
while there's subbing division around
race or who is American or who America
is for there's unanimity that Julian
Assange and WikiLeaks are good and that
US intervention in Syria is bad those
are the two things that are almost
universally that's the net effected a
very next one
so this is an anti-war opposition Syria
yeah they leaned into that for the
left-leaning pages again that's not
surprising there are large parts of the
American Left that you know particularly
Bernie Sanders supporters Jill Stein
supporters who have very strong anti-war
beliefs and that is a driving force
behind their vote and so they so they
leverage those two to reach that
audience and the next one is another
anti-war and this is that oh that was
yeah that was targeting veterans that
was like mocking the idea that
Isis was so sometimes the memes didn't
necessarily the visuals didn't match the
text so the text is telling you that
Isis is our real enemy not Bashar
al-assad and so they're trying to again
like redirect why are we you know why is
the u.s. messing around in Syria Isis is
the if is the thing but this meme of
course has nothing really to do with
Bashar al-assad this is just saying that
the u.s. you know aircraft carriers
totally dominate Isis is a little truck
convoy there yep yep and then the
redirecting attention away from Bashar
al so all these types of things are yeah
yeah that leveraging anonymous as well
yeah well I know this is a great you
know gets co-opted at all the time right
it because because of what it is it's
very nature it's like this independent
hacktivists collective anyone can kind
of self declare and and and and
participate but it also provides an
interesting opportunity for them to kind
of piggyback on that activist freedom
fighting brand and since the assumption
is that anonymous are anonymous the idea
that some random anonymous page springs
up and starts memeing is not something
that you would necessarily give a second
glance to yep you know and then we have
alleged the alleged voter fraud as well
this was also another thing that puts
people into uproar is seeing memes like
this yeah and they have six different
six different voter fraud violations
that they're talking about they're
putting this out on Twitter they're
putting it out on Winnie tree Instagram
do we know I think I don't think it was
fraud it was like the voting machine
problems and things like that you think
are you know somewhere in America on a
given Election Day some voting machine
is having a problem yeah but is it
purposely being made right now once you
have that screenshot of course you can
make hay of it particularly if you've
spent or synthesize it yourself did you
tell that true that lets you but you can
reach out to your audience and you can
amplify this as an example of like we
told you this was going to happen we
told you Hillary was gonna steal the
election no here it is
here it is realized and then the
influence on the Republican Party this
is again this is oh yeah that's just
ordinary stuff yeah so these slides were
prepared in the course of several
briefings for Senate staffers and others
we're trying to convey quickly as
possible here are things that happened
and it's interesting to convey that
particularly realizing that some of the
people who see your briefing are the
people who were targeted and so trying
to figure out how to how to convey the
fact that this is regardless of what you
think of President Trump this is a
nonpartisan issue and two of the
senators who appear in these images who
were targeted were senator Cruz and
senator Rubio and so trying to reinforce
the universality of this as a problem
for America as opposed to a problem for
the Democrats or a problem for the
Republicans is I think one of the
reasons why it's so important to to try
to to try to get at this kind of these
kinds of narratives why was their
approach from slant these questions 20
the next one is in the 2016 election one
of the assets Trump we need closer
relations with Russia against Putin's
support this is that the United Muslims
of America is to save support Hillary
yep yeah and then the next one is also
vote for Jill Stein you mentioned this a
little bit earlier and Russian troll the
next one is Russian trolls on Russia
trolls this was kind of at the very
these are funny I mean yeah this is like
you can't you can't not find this at
least a little bit a little bit funny
mommy there are monsters under my bed
it's probably just the Russians you know
this
that one but that I mean that's a great
that's a great ad campaign it's an ad
campaign by Archie and they so the
Archie ad campaign for a while they're
in Moscow Airport was that's the plane
lost an election blame it on us yeah
come closer I find out who we're gonna
hack next right I mean it's um you you
you know yeah so they said this is also
the type of stuff that gets people to
think of it's just mocking it's
basically mocking it the next asset is
another little bit of mocking yeah the
idea of Russian interference and
propaganda you know so just the idea of
this mocking it's a reinforcing thing
it's like oh there's no way there's no
way there's no way and if it just keep
circling then then where's the nuance
right you've lost the nuance completely
and just these last two asses one homes
and Pietschmann narratives which I
thought is another one of those that was
an interesting thing that surprised me
so the LGBT page you know of course was
antitrump but more than that after after
the election happened it was interesting
to see oh this was the born liberal but
the LGBT page said it to Mike Pence's
worse than Donald Trump so we shouldn't
push for impeachment yeah and so it was
it was an interesting way to look at how
they reworked the narrative following
the election how do you continue to
drive grievances and sow discord and
make people feel under attack you know
you're just kind of switching prior to
the election it was like reinforcing to
the right that they were under attack so
they had to get out and vote because
Hillary Clinton was gonna steal the
election immediately after Donald Trump
wins the election the narrative becomes
the electoral college is illegitimate we
need to be protesting in the streets
because he stole the election you know
or but but not you know the Russians had
nothing to do with it simultaneously and
then well we don't want them to like
think the guy is guilty of something and
move to impeach so let's talk about how
much Mike Pence saw
you know and then the last slide is the
quantitative numbers on the Trump versus
Clinton yeah you made it yeah
summary stats yeah and again it was the
just kind of I think it's included in
here I'm not sure that summary stats on
mentions is really the defining
narrative as you look an aggregate at
the at the campaign but what we wanted
to get at was the idea that this was not
at least partially about the election at
the moments in which that mattered like
that just wasn't true it wasn't the
biggest part by any stretch it was a
small percentage of the content they
were much more focused on American
society but they were they did have a
political alignment and in terms of
electoral politics and they did
reinforce it during that period of time
because what you're gonna have is you're
gonna have in 2016 all the whatever
happens Clinton Trump is going to
dissipate more so but then you'll have
all the things that were tribalism
identity politics those things will stay
yeah they'll stay and had this not been
uncovered right
those those assets those pages that they
had created would have stayed and they
would have continued to influence and
they would have continued to and then
you would you know one of the things we
did find pages that were still active
while we were doing this and then we
gave them to the Senate which gave them
to Facebook because I at the time was
not to communicate directly with the
platforms everything was you know it was
my community the Senate yeah and and we
did say hey there are some here's some
stuff here's some assets that look to
still be active and so they they came
down and that was content that was not
English language that was content that
was Arabic actually I'm focused on Syria
and but the you you could tell based on
certain assets that they used and then
the other thing the thing that is not in
the slide deck is the overt propaganda
networks and so that's our tea and
Sputnik and so you see Artie and Sputnik
embedding tweets by Russian troll
accounts that Twitter identified that
pointed to Facebook pages and so you you
see the way in which the overt you know
state funded arm of the media Artie and
Sputnik are amplifying these patrol
accounts now of course we have no idea
if they knew that they were troll
accounts that is you know again there
are coincidences in the world yeah yeah
and I and this is a good way to just
wrap I do think that some of the crazy
stuff about this is that a we have to
figure out how we knew these were troll
accounts we have to figure out how we
know all of the we're always the rest of
the data and how can we get that data
how can we open source it make it easier
for us to be able to analyze it also how
can we prevent future internet
propaganda that is trying to be
disrupted that's trying to be just
destructive that it's trying to push
people away from each other instead of
having nuanced discourse with one
another so I'm curious in in a you know
maybe there is a way to get like a
whistleblower that comes out from the
IRA and says that this is all that's
happened
oh yeah that's happened several times
yeah they've been a bunch of them
Ludmila savage oh yeah so she went
undercover there and rode next was a
some of the best early coverage of the
internet research agency was done by
russian press there's i think it like
translator it's too like RB k sometimes
it's r bc but it was a russian site that
has some fantastic data visualizations
in which russian trolls talk about their
quotas for the day and how they decided
what to post and and has visualizations
on pages and things like that and
actually from that i think we found the
names of like two or three pages because
that article came out before my you know
before the senate investigation started
yeah i mean they know because the
internet research agency used to target
a russian and ukrainian citizens it
didn't start looking out at america yeah
it started internally internally focused
so investigative journalists in russia
we're interested in it as a function of
what what is it what is it pushing to
russian people and here's some you know
here's an example and you know ron if
you want to if you want to pull up the
NDI this is this person that's not exist
comm DCI Ronnie yeah cool
just this is the generative adversarial
network again and this is something to
test with your friends you know you can
just refresh the page if you want and
you can find another completely
synthesized face of someone that doesn't
exist click refresh again and so these
are the types of things that you know we
were discussing a little bit ago with
that video that Trump posted about and
Nancy Pelosi and is that actually what
percent is fake down you know that
that's it that's a fascinating question
right which is like we've had we've had
computer movie monsters for forever
right and and and there are certain you
know fiction is a thing of course and
and so technology to fabricate is not
new Photoshop is old but as the
technology changes we we have you can
rather than rather than edit something
you can create it and that's the
difference so a true deep fake is not an
edit it's not a splicing together of
videos it's actually having the AI
generate the content and that's distinct
what Trump tweeted with Nancy Pelosi my
understanding based on being on Twitter
last night was that that was sort of
edited real footage there were a couple
of videos of her that were floating
around last night were and one she'd
been slowed down to make her sound drunk
that is more of like manipulation of
real footage which is a thing that has
existed in the world for a while as
opposed to also last week on the
Internet
the generative audio of Joe Rogan yeah
correct right where Joe has so much
content on the internet podcasts YouTube
videos you know audio just tons of it
and so what so you use the existing data
to train the AI and so if you're a
public figure who has a sufficient
amount of images of your face and then
the sound of your voice out there people
can make a deep pick of you saying
whatever it is that they want to make
you say and it's not real and it's not
an edit of footage it is brand-new
footage so people can't go back you know
video editors can can look and see like
this video was slowed down this video
was sped up this video was spliced when
the video is generated at a full cloth
you it as the technology improves it's
much harder for someone to forensic ly
say like is this a secret leaked audio
recording of Joe Rogan or Nancy Pelosi
taken in some dark alley somewhere that
they don't want you to know about yeah
yeah this is this is the pressing issue
we have to become better critical
thinkers we're all talking about this
how do we do that how do we teach kids
out how do we teach adults that how do
we geopolitically work together moving
forward these are some of the most
pressing questions of our time through
that social technology age that's why we
talk about these things on the show and
Rene this has been such a pleasure yeah
well it's the least we can do for the
months and months of work like thank you
and also hopefully we can inspire other
people to like we say have a vaccine of
critical thinking against some of this
type of content that can come up do you
think we're in a simulation that's such
an interesting question my inclination
is no but that you know I just
I sort of prefer the simplest
explanation which is you know we're here
but I am NOT a student of physics and so
I I follow the I follow the conversation
I don't think I have anything really
intelligent to add to it how about you
two just to be on time I can tell you
afterward um but what what do you what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in the world oh my kids I know that's
it's your mom answer but I'm just like
all right look at them and I'm amazed
yeah Renee this has been such a pleasure
I really appreciate you coming in for
teaching us thank you for having me
thank you yeah thank you for all your
hard work yeah there's a lot to Street a
lot still talk about the vaccines how we
make the vaccines happen the critical
thinking vaccines that that can prevent
the the craziness from spreading around
the world further and unity that we need
everyone thank you so much for tuning
and we greatly appreciate we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
in the episode get talking to more of
your friends your family or coworkers
people online on social media about
disinformation media and trust get
talking about it also check out the
links below renee deressa comm her
twitter no upside also download the
white paper in the slide deck at
disinformation report comm and share
those with people around you also this
person does not exist comm share that
Gann with people get talking about it
also huge shout out to Ron Vargas are
producing and directing thank you for
doing this long show Ron we really
appreciate it and also support the
organization's the entrepreneurs the
artists around the world that you
believe in simulations links are below
support us help us scale and grow our
impact and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon that
[Music]